[Musica]
nella mia vita Faccio il designer
disegno ogni cosa
e Da cosa nasce cosa
ma da piccolo Non immaginavo che potesse
diventare il mio lavoro
passavo ora a guardare il cielo
di giorno cercavo le forme delle nuvole
e mi piaceva aspettare le nuove forme
che il vento stava creando
di notte invece chiudendo gli occhi mi
proiettavo in una dimensione immaginaria
spaziale fatta di persone animali
fantastici satelliti orbite pianeti
una dimensione che somiglia a quella che
state vedendo anche voi
somiglia perché ognuno di noi qui può
riconoscere una cosa diversa
Chi di voi ha visto la spuma del mare o
la bocca di un vulcano
o la pupilla di un gatto
Chi di voi ha riconosciuto la luna
e ha pensato di conoscerla anche se non
c'è mai stato
con il tempo Perciò ho maturato la mia
personale opinione che senza esperienza
diretta non si può conoscere veramente
una cosa
Ecco perché credo che il conoscere sia
più importante del riconoscere
nella comunicazione Infatti un Brand è
più importante di un logo
Ma voi sapete cos'è un brand e Cos'è un
logo
il logo è il segno grafico che rende
riconoscibile un'azienda Proprio come la
fisionomia di una persona
Il Brand invece
rappresenta i valori identitari
dell'azienda
include il logo e mira a costruire una
relazione autentica con le persone
proprio come facciamo nelle nostre
relazioni
più o meno intime
con la diffusione di internet e l'uso
dei social network Il Brand rimbalzato
dalla affissione alla televisione per
atterrare dentro l'oggetto più intimo
che abbiamo lo smartphone la nostra
scatola magica lì abbiamo possibilità di
consultazione 24 ore su 7 giorni ci
Trasformiamo da consumatore a persona
lì possiamo dialogare con un brand per
la prima volta in tempo reale
e per la prima volta possiamo stabilire
una relazione autentica con le persone
oggi un brand per comunicare deve
parlare alle persone
non più al consumatore Ma le persone
un Brand funziona Se ammette e chiede
scusa
se riconosce i propri errori si aderisce
a valori che rispettino la natura e le
differenze
in sintesi un brand per funzionare deve
essere più umano
Vi è mai capitato di ricordare una
pubblicità senza associarla un logo
non so se avete presente lo spot di
un'automobile che schivava le esplosioni
di vernice colorata
Quanti di voi ricordano con esattezza
quale fosse la marca
nessuno
e se vi chiedessi di ricordare lo slogan
La potenza è nulla senza controllo
Quanti di voi Ricordano la marca
lui è Karl Lewis nove volte campione
olimpico chiamato figlio del vento in
questo caso alcuni di voi hanno
riconosciuto Qual è la marca
e se vi chiedessi invece di immaginare
una schiacciata canestro
di quale Brand sto parlando
bene alcuni di voi hanno capito che sto
parlando di Michael Jordan
questo però Dimostra come alcune aziende
anche investendo importanti budget hanno
problemi di comunicazione
per risolvere questo problema abbiamo
teorizzato applicato sperimentato
modificato e scritto la metodologia del
Dynamic Brand dove l'azienda pur
mantenendo i propri valori i valori è in
continua connessione con le persone
si tratta di un nuovo modo di comunicare
che sostituisce la tradizionale
struttura gerarchica
con il Dynamic Brand cambia
l'architettura organizzativa della
comunicazione
non esiste più lo schema verticale
composto da logo corporete dentiti
advertising video spot user Experience
Digital eccetera ma l'architettura della
comunicazione diventa realmente
integrata
il Dynamic Brand mette al centro i
valori
visivamente lavora sul sistema di
identità il logo viene portato fuori
deresponsabilizzato e funziona al pari
di tutti gli altri media per dar vita ad
una comunicazione
coerente in questo modo riusciamo anche
ad ottimizzare i budget di investimento
il Dynamic Brand è qualcosa che
coinvolge che rivoluzione che fa
veramente arrivare i valori dell'azienda
lo vediamo ogni volta che progettiamo
con i nostri clienti Questo è quello che
succede il centro il cuore sono i tuoi
valori sono i valori della tua azienda e
di tutte le persone che insieme a te
concretizzano il tuo sogno
così Disegniamo un sistema di identità
che non lavora più sullo spot
pubblicitario sulla forma ma sul
contenuto
e ogni volta possiamo scegliere con
quali media o tecnologia esprimerlo
è il motivo per cui l'identità dinamica
È riconoscibile anche in assenza di Logo
Ma quand'è che esiste l'identità
l'identità
esiste quando c'è la diversità
ad esempio non c'è ombra senza luce
e al contrario non c'è luce senza ombra
senza il proprio posto anche la luce
sarebbe qualcosa di non percepito
pensiamo alla bellezza degli opposti il
bianco e il nero
racchiudono tutte le infinite sfumature
di colore proprio come una finestra che
si apre sul mondo
il contatto con le diversità suggerisce
l'evoluzione
quindi più conosciamo e più abbiamo una
visione oggettiva del mondo di ciò che
preferiamo di ciò che scegliamo
in questo modo possiamo costruire la
nostra vera identità
Vi è mai capitato non so quando tornate
da un viaggio non dico che siete diversi
ma vi sentite arricchiti
c'è una sfumatura in voi che grazie a
quel nuovo paesaggio a quei nuovi Sapori
a quei nuovi colori ai vostri nuovi
occhi
ha stimolato qualcosa in voi che
sembrava stupito
per questo
L'identità è nella diversità
per questo un Brand o un personal Brand
hanno lo stesso principio
la tua azienda tu come persona Quante
sfumature hai
quante cose vorresti fare emergere che
non conosci
nella tua azienda Quanti punti di vista
ci sono che non conosci e che ti
piacerebbe avere
Ecco cosa significa
costruire un universo visivo
che evolve che interagisce che si
confronta che sceglie
un universo visivo capace di mutare con
il mutare del mondo
di tutti noi
capace di scavalcare il presente
proiettarsi nel futuro
in cui come vi raccontavo il conoscere
vale di più
anche quando pensiamo che il futuro sia
lontano come la luna e ci rendiamo conto
invece che il futuro è già tra noi come
le persone
the futures
[Applauso]
[Musica]